and that's what happens.
It out-gasses formaldehyde --
so much so that there is a federal law in place
to warn new mobile home buyers of the formaldehyde atmosphere danger.
Are we just being numbingly stupid?
The walls are this thick.
The whole thing has the structural value of corn.
(Laughter)
"So ... I thought Palm Harbor Village was over there."
"No, no. We had a wind last night.
It's gone now."
(Laughter)
Then when they degrade, what do you do with them?
Now, all that --
that Apollonian, Platonic model --
is what the building industry is predicated on,
and there are a number of things that exacerbate that.
One is that all the professionals,
all the tradesmen, vendors,
inspectors, engineers, architects
all think like this.
And then it works its way back to the consumer,
who demands the same model.
It's a self-fulfilling prophecy. We can't get out of it.
Then here come the marketeers and the advertisers.
"Woo. Woo-hoo."
We buy stuff we didn't know we needed.
All we have to do is look at what one company did
with carbonated prune juice.
How disgusting.
(Laughter)
But you know what they did?
They hooked a metaphor into it and said, "I drink Dr. Pepper ..."
And pretty soon, we're swilling that stuff by the lake-ful,
by the billions of gallons.
It doesn't even have real prunes! Doesn't even keep you regular.
(Laughter)
My oh my, that makes it worse.
And we get sucked into that faster than anything.
Then, a man named Jean-Paul Sartre wrote a book
titled "Being and Nothingness."
It's a pretty quick read. You can snap through it in maybe --
(Laughter)
maybe two years,
if you read eight hours a day.
In there, he talked about the divided self.
He said human beings act differently when they know they're alone
than when they know somebody else is around.
So if I'm eating spaghetti, and I know I'm alone,
I can eat like a backhoe.
I can wipe my mouth on my sleeve, napkin on the table,
chew with my mouth open, make little noises,
scratch wherever I want.
(Laughter)
But as soon as you walk in,
I go, "Oops! Lil' spaghetti sauce there."
Napkin in my lap, half-bites,
chew with my mouth closed, no scratching.
Now, what I'm doing is fulfilling your expectations
of how I should live my life.
I feel that expectation,
and so I accommodate it,
and I'm living my life according to what you expect me to do.
That happens in the building industry as well.
That's why all subdivisions look the same.
Sometimes, we even have these formalized cultural expectations.
I'll bet all your shoes match.
Sure enough, we all buy into that ...
(Laughter)
And with gated communities,
we have a formalized expectation,
with a homeowners' association.
Sometimes those guys are Nazis,
my oh my.
That exacerbates and continues this model.
The last thing is gregariousness.
Human beings are a social species.
We like to hang together in groups,
just like wildebeests, just like lions.
Wildebeests don't hang with lions,
because lions eat wildebeests.
Human beings are like that.
We do what that group does
that we're trying to identify with.
You see this in junior high a lot.
Those kids, they'll work all summer long -- kill themselves --
so that they can afford one pair of designer jeans.
So along about September,
they can stride in and go,
"I'm important today. See? Don't touch my designer jeans!
I see you don't have designer jeans.
You're not one of the beautiful -- See, I'm one of the beautiful people.
See my jeans?"
Right there is reason enough to have uniforms.
And so that happens in the building industry as well.
We have confused Maslow's hierarchy of needs,
just a little bit.
On the bottom tier, we have basic needs:
shelter, clothing, food, water, mating and so forth.
Second: security. Third: relationships.
Fourth: status, self-esteem -- that is, vanity --
and we're taking vanity and shoving it down here.
And so we end up
with vain decisions,
and we can't even afford our mortgage.
We can't afford to eat anything except beans;
that is, our housing has become a commodity.
And it takes a little bit of nerve
to dive into those primal,
terrifying parts of ourselves
and make our own decisions
and not make our housing a commodity,
but make it something that bubbles up from seminal sources.
That takes a little bit of nerve,
and, darn it, once in a while, you fail.
But that's okay.
If failure destroys you,
then you can't do this.
I fail all the time, every day,
and I've had some whopping failures, I promise --
big, public, humiliating, embarrassing failures.
Everybody points and laughs,
and they say, "He tried it a fifth time, and it still didn't work!
What a moron!"
Early on, contractors come by and say,
"Dan, you're a cute little bunny,
but you know, this just isn't going to work.
What don't you do this? Why don't you do that?"
And your instinct is to say,
"Well, why don't you suck an egg?"
(Laughter)
But you don't say that,
because they're the guys you're targeting.
And so what we've done --
and this isn't just in housing; it's in clothing and food
and our transportation needs, our energy --
we sprawl just a little bit.
And when I get a little bit of press,
I hear from people all over the world.
And we may have invented excess,
but the problem of waste is worldwide.
We're in trouble.
And I don't wear ammo belts crisscrossing my chest
and a red bandana.
But we're clearly in trouble.
And what we need to do is reconnect
with those really primal parts of ourselves
and make some decisions and say,
"You know, I think I would like to put CDs across the wall there.
What do you think, honey?"
If it doesn't work, take it down.
What we need to do is reconnect with who we really are,
and that's thrilling indeed.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)